>> Female: From the Library of Congress in Washington, DC.
[Music]
>> Gary Sinise: My mother has always talked about the Library of Congress
to me, and I have never, never been here, and I'm just -
I'm overwhelmed by what I've seen today, and sharing the day
with my daughter has been very special,
wonderful, surprising, and awe-inspiring.
>> James Billington: You can see this has got wood carving _____.
>> Gary Sinise: Today, I was made aware
that there actually is this archival project
to record personal histories of veterans.
I had no idea.
>> Robert Patrick: Well, the Library
of Congress Veterans History Project has been an ongoing effort here
since 2000.
The purpose of this project is to get the human experience of war,
what veterans feel about - the experience,
what it meant to them, how it's affected them.
Everybody's story's important, from machine gunners to musicians.
And that's what we've been trying to create with this project
of having people - every solder, every airman, Marine, sailor,
tell their story and become a part of what has become a very rich
and used collection here at the Library.
It's gonna be able to capture those from World War I all the way
up to the current conflict.
And we do it primarily through oral histories and the collection
of materials that veterans have sent into us.
>> Gary Sinise: How do you decide who to interview,
or is it can anybody - any veteran -?
>> Robert Patrick: There's 17 million living wartime veterans.
Any veteran -
>> Gary Sinise: They just contact you
and say they're coming, or how's it work?
>> Robert Patrick: Well, it's done by volunteers.
We have volunteer organizations doing it.
And then we had this document, which is a field kit that we use
that anybody can sit down with a family member
and actually record one of these interviews.
It's as simple as pulling out the video camera
or the cassette tape recorder -
>> Gary Sinise: And just send it into you?
>> Robert Patrick: - and send it into us, and they become a part
of the Library of Congress.
I know your family has a rich veterans tradition.
Your personal and professional involvement with veterans,
I know they're clear to your heart.
So I'd like to show you a couple of the collections we have
so you can get kind of a feel for what we have.
The first I'd like to start with is a short clip of a veteran -
a Vietnam veteran named Artie Guerrero.
Artie was drafted in 1967, was thrown right into combat,
and was very seriously wounded in Vietnam.
>> Artie Guerrero: I never thought of myself
as being courageous, but self-sustaining.
That's the part of the animalistic instinct that comes out of you
when you're put in a barbaric situation like war.
You're not the same civilized mind that you're once taught to be
or the person that you are.
And I've suffered these consequences,
and you just don't come back the same.
You suffered the post-traumatic stress disorder.
It never leaves you.
>> Robert Patrick: Artie is wheelchair-bound, but is an advocate
for veterans out in California.
The project has about 78,000 collections.
We're told to get the older veterans first.
We have about 48,000 of those from World War II,
but we're really starting to focus on Vietnam veterans.
They're not getting any younger, either, and we're really hoping
to bring in more and more.
We have about 10,000 of those collections here now.
Now let talk about entertaining the troops,
which I know you're involved with.
This is Robert Sidney.
Robert Sidney is a World War II veteran, and he was enlisted
into the Army to be a part of a show called "This is the Army."
I don't know if you've heard about this -
>> Gary Sinise: Sure, yeah.
>> Robert Patrick: Well, he was their first sergeant,
and Irving Berlin, who set up that show, enlisted him to kind
of be the first sergeant for the troop.
When the show was set up, it was on Broadway.
It was hit on Broadway.
Then they took it over to England, and it was hit there.
Played at the Palladium and everyone loved it,
but then they were gonna disband the show,
until General Eisenhower showed up.
>> Robert Sidney: Eisenhower got wind of that,
and that's when he came to see the show.
And after the show, he came back stage.
We were called to attention, and he said, "At ease, men.
At ease." And he said, "I want to tell you, I sat out there
in that audience, and if you can do for the GIs what you did for me,
brought up so many wonderful memories of home,
you're the biggest morale factor we have to offer these men in arms"
>> Robert Patrick: What went on then, the show was reconfigured,
sent literally around the world.
And what Robert has done here is this is the itinerary for the shows.
Also, in his collection, there's some very touching letters
from Irving Berlin to him.
This is Irving Berlin at a medical ward
out in the Pacific - singing to the troops.
This is him in front of a poster in Rome.
An interesting part about this troop, it was integrated.
Most of the units in World War II were segregated.
I don't know if you have these backstage at any of your shows
of guys dressing up for their performance.
And, in fact, your story
of what you've been doing can become a part of this project.
>> Gary Sinise: I think there's probably several veterans
that don't have any idea that that's even available or needed or wanted,
but I know others that would be grateful for the opportunity
to have something preserved,
some part of their history that's important to them preserved here
at the Library of Congress.
Female: This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.